all of these financial institutions they
buy politicians you can take this big
ton of money and then you can start to
buy people let me tell you it's not
there who's the president
and serious controlling the wallet
the hedge funds
these guys
[Music]
a couple of years ago we released this
legendary video BlackRock the company
that owns the world with over 3.5
million views but back then we only had
secondhand information to go off of but
now we have this guy Sergey Varley a
BlackRock recruiter exposing it all
thanks to an undercover operation by
James O'Keefe first there's the sentence
I'll give you 500k right now no
questions asked yeah identity volatility
creates opportunity to make profits
for business you're like a undercover
reporter I don't know that's what normal
people think this is this is beyond them
so now from the horse's mouth itself
here's a simple guide on how to actually
rule the world
[Music]
foreign
step number one to rule the world you
first need to control an obscene amount
of money see money gets you to the big
boys table and when you're at the big
boys table that's where you can actually
start influencing how the world Works
anybody who wants to go into politics
they're all puppets there are 150 and
they're all men that run the world
period full stop they control most of
the important assets they control the
money flows and these are not the tech
entrepreneurs now they they are going to
get rolled over over the next five to
ten years by the people that are really
underneath pulling the strings and when
you get behind the curtain and see how
that world Works what you realize is it
is unfairly set up for them and their
progeny first order of business is I
want to break through and be at that
table that's the first order of business
and the way that I do that is by proving
that I can do what they do as well as
they do it and then do it better than
how they do it because at the end of the
day they are commercial animals okay and
they'll open the door out of curiosity
City and they'll let me stay because
because I add value but it all starts
with money you acquire
you diversify you acquire you keep
acquiring you spend whatever you make
and acquiring more and at certain point
your breast level is super low like
imagine you've invested in 10 different
industries from food to to drinks to
like technology right one of them fails
doesn't matter you have nine others to
pick you up the risk management is
inherently in just about everything and
in the finance space it's all about the
money you make you don't you don't love
it set you like you could be using it
over and over and exponential growth you
want a little bit of everything and that
little bit of everything gives you so
much money on a yearly basis and that's
exactly what BlackRock did today
BlackRock has more than nine trillion
dollars of assets under managements and
you know what that means right it means
that if BlackRock was a country they
would be the fourth biggest country in
the world in terms of assets surpassed
only by Japan China and the US that
means BlackRock is bigger than the UK
bigger than Germany bigger than France
Canada Italy and they own a percentage
of every single major company in
existence so BlackRock is now in this
position where not only do they have
this incredible influence over every
single company out there but now if all
they did was sit back and do nothing
they would still get another half a
trillion dollars every year if all they
did was grow their asses by another five
percent now that is power it's why their
assets under management is projected to
hit 15 trillion dollars by 2028 and now
that you own a little bit of everything
you now have this bird's eye view of the
entire economy that no one else can see
think about it if you can see where
money is flowing into and out of for the
entire economy that is insanely valuable
so now it's time to use this advantage
to make yourself useful to the
governments so useful that the
government starts to become dependent on
you
aside from the public companies that
BlackRock is invested in like Coca-Cola
BlackRock also has their grubby little
fingers inside of a bunch of private
companies as well to the tune of tens of
billions of dollars and this is what
their private Equity division and why is
Blackrock in private Equity because
private Equity is where you're able to
get in early on exclusive companies
before they go public before they
potentially go to the Moon while also
giving BlackRock a lot more influence on
the company from the inside like imagine
if you got into Tesla just before they
went public that is private Equity
investing private Equity investing has
traditionally been reserved for giants
like BlackRock who can write million
dollar checks to private companies and
on top of that the downside of private
Equity is that typically your money
isn't very liquid it's not like the
stock market where you can just sell
your shares whenever you want so
typically your money is locked in for
years at a time which is not ideal but
what if you could have the best of both
worlds what if you could get exposure to
some of the most Innovative private
companies while also having the
liquidity of a publicly traded stock
well that is where stock Capital comes
in today's paid sponsor if you've heard
of reiter a real estate investment
trusts where you buy a read stock to get
exposure to real estate it's the same
idea here but with private Equity stack
capital invests in really Innovative
private companies like SpaceX Hopper
Locus Robotics and more that way if you
buy stack Capital stock it would be kind
of like if you invested in the SpaceX
and all these other companies as well
except since you're putting your money
into a publicly traded stock you can
sell way easier than compared to private
Equity of course this still comes with
all the same risks as any investment and
I am not a registered financial advisor
but if you've been itching to get access
to these type of companies this might be
a good route for you you can learn more
about what companies that capital is
invested in by scrolling down and
clicking the link below scroll down and
click the link below to learn more about
stock Capital now
[Music]
step number two make yourself
indispensable to the governments
economic simulation convenient to
understand the impact of something like
they're gonna like raise the interest
for example it's gonna create a
successful various factors they're not
sure what's going to do basically this
is where blackrock's secretive financial
markets Advisory Group comes in now
blackrock's Financial Market advisories
group sounds like a vague unassuming
division of the company and on paper
this division does not even make
BlackRock all that much money but the
secret division is by far blackrock's
most important the financial markets
Advisory Group does everything from risk
analysis to stress testing asset
valuations for groups like The European
Central Bank the government of Greece
and of course America's federal reserve
and by offering services that no one
else can provide to Big Business and the
governments BlackRock started racking up
a lot of political Goodwill with the
most important decision makers in the
world this allows BlackRock to have a
hand inside almost every major Central
Bank and financial Authority in the
world just imagine the kind of Insider
information
half at your fingertips if you were the
one helping central banks around the
world make decisions recession's Major
Market crashes decisions to raise
interest rates to lower interest rates
if we already know that politicians have
repeatedly done insider trading on these
things in the past it's safe to assume
that BlackRock definitely knows about
all these things well in advance way
before they happen especially when
they're the ones helping these
politicians make the decisions today
BlackRock has become completely and
utterly entrenched in the American
governments along with many other
institutions around the world the
government asked Blackwater to help
organize the sale of bear Stearns after
the 2008 financial crisis they asked
BlackRock to help with the bond buyback
program during covid and BlackRock has
even helped a Vatican get their finances
in order and when you've infiltrated
governments this deeply it makes buying
off the politicians that much easier
step number three buy yourself a few
politicians all of these financial
institutions they buy politicians
who is controlling the wallet
first there's the senator
you got 10 grand you can buy it so I can
give you 500k right now no questions
asked yeah it doesn't matter who wins
here's what you have to understand about
politics it's like even though they look
and sound all-powerful on TV these
politicians are nothing they don't have
any actual power they are merely puppets
most of them don't start out with any
money so in order to get elected they
have the best friend wealthy donors like
you and when you actually get them
elected most American Senators for
example only make a measly 174 thousand
dollars a year which means these puppets
are incredibly easy to bribe think about
it if all you offer them was five
hundred thousand dollars that's almost
triple their yearly salary so of course
they're gonna bend over and take it 500
000 for you is quite literally chunk
change so it's a pretty good deal but
keep in mind in the US there are
campaign contribution limits but don't
worry because there are plenty of ways
for a politician to receive five hundred
thousand dollars worth of value from you
without you actually having to wire them
five hundred thousand dollars wink wink
you just gotta get creative and now that
you have the politicians in your pocket
now it's time to double down on one of
the most profitable Arenas War
foreign
[Music]
bank with the Ukrainian government to
help rebuild the country and attract
private Investments and even though
BlackRock said they're going to be
offering their help for free this move
will put Blackrock in the perfect
position to get in early on all the best
investments think about it if Ukraine
wins this war it's safe to assume that
America is just going to dump even more
money into the country to rebuild and
take it over and BlackRock will be in
the perfect position to know about it
first and capitalize that's why
companies like BlackRock are doing
everything in their power to keep the
war going because the more damage the
work creates the more reconstruction
will be needed if my crane is good for
business
if you own shares in Lockheed Martin
Raytheon and Boeing just like BlackRock
does then war is great for business if
you have contacts in the government that
tell you when Ukraine's grain Saddles
are blown up or when America is going to
sanction Russian natural gas so you can
profit off of it war is great for
business if you own shares in the
companies that are eventually going to
be hired to rebuild Ukraine war is great
for business
[Music]
and from there you're kind of set
because again if all you did right now
is Blackrock was just sit back and let
your money compound it will practically
be impossible for anyone to catch up to
you you'll keep getting more and more
embedded with governments around the
world as you continue helping them
you'll continue buying more politicians
you'll continue getting first dips on
the most lucrative Investments out there
and you'll continue profiting off of
crises as they happen all you gotta do
is make sure you continue operating in
the shadows staying out of the Limelight
as much as possible they've only been
the news they they don't want people to
talk about them they don't want to be
anywhere on the radar
but I suspect it's probably because it's
easier to do things than people aren't
thinking about it but let's be real even
if the masses did realize what you were
up to they're not gonna do anything
about it they're too preoccupied with
Tick Tock paying their rents on where
they're gonna go out this weekend to
care
this is beyond them so that is a cycle
of Life first you get the money then you
get the power then you get everything
this country you gotta make the money
first
then when you get the money you get the
power
let me get the power
then you get the woman
that's why you've got to make your own
moves
[Music]